i did want to quickly start though with
um what happened in washington earlier
this week
um we've been asking lawmakers about
their reaction to it
um your thoughts as you watched the riot
take place up on capitol hill
well i think what we saw his attack on
democracy uh plain and simple
um everybody's entitled to their own
opinion uh four years ago
uh donald trump became president and
those of us
who recognized that he did not win the
popular vote uh didn't simply
you know uh plot to take over the
capital
um we accepted that this is our process
and we organized to be ready in in the
four following years
so to see this type of attack um
uh on our on our capital is an attack on
our own government on democracy
um it is clearly uh domestic terrorism
in my opinion
i'm glad that the federal authorities
are looking at charging individuals that
they can identify
um you know but you know you can't uh go
into anarchy when you just don't get
your way
uh so we had an election we were
committed to making sure that that
election was as inclusive as possible
and we have to live with the the results
of that and that's democracy so
um uh i was disappointed to see it and i
think
anyone who cares about uh our government
and democracy
uh would also uh speak out against that
type of violence
and then i am um you know i'm really
looking forward to
the country and the state coming
together to start to get back to doing
the work uh
of the people uh that we represent no
obviously i
understand as a state lawmaker there's
you can't do much about what happens
at the state of the national capital but
uh there was a call by state democrats
uh call for resignations and so forth so
can you fill me in on your position on
that
you mean uh i'm sorry
i'll ask the question again i beg your
pardon uh
there were there was a call to for
resignations
um by state democrats uh
just sort of a call to action including
one of your
fellow assembly members on the other
side of the party um
can you speak to that a little bit uh
what your what the
expectation is well when you say
resignations resignations by who by
by the president by uh members of the
legislature
uh i think it's a different conversation
depending on on
who we're talking about well i think
specifically i was
annie black was at the rally and uh
she was included on a list of of folks
that nevada democrats say should
step down um i guess can you elaborate
more on on the concerns or the uh
thoughts you have on her and other uh
republicans taking part in what happened
yesterday
well to the to what extent they took
part we don't know uh i'm gonna get
ready for session
i'm gonna get ready to do the work for
the people of our our state
um to the extent that we get more
information about
any individual who was involved in
rioting or or damaging property or
breaking into the capital
um i've yet to see that i'm gonna plan
on getting ready for session
um you know going to washington dc
uh is one thing breaking into the
capital was another
uh and so uh we're going to get ready
for session and focus on the things that
that
that you know help us operate as a state
and if we get more information it
indicates that any individual is engaged
in uh unlawful activity
um you know i think that we have
precedent that the legislature
is the only entity that can judge the
the qualifications of our own members
and so we'll have a conversation um if
more information is
uh provided that that i think
shows any criminal activity okay well
let's talk about the legislative session
um it's there's a lot on the menu um
what are you let's just start with the
the top priorities that you have
uh when the session gets underway well
look i mean you know
at the top of the list for me is is
making sure that we have
an environment where we can conduct the
business of the state in a safe way and
that means keeping members safe keeping
staff safe
keeping any stakeholders and members of
the public that may engage in the
process safe
i think that this is a struggle that
many states are having with how to
accomplish that
uh you know i think you know what we've
seen happen in other states is
concerning and so that's going to
probably weigh into
uh how we function but that's going to
be our number one priority making sure
we have an environment
where we can do our business safely uh
obviously nevada
has been one of the hardest hit states
in the country uh with this pandemic
it has you know really significantly
crippled our budget
and we already made uh some tough
decisions and cut our state budget by 30
um and that's a state budget that was
already one of the most lean in the
country so
uh we're gonna have to you know live
within our means and
deal with the uh further budgets you
know restraints
and then beyond that i think our
priorities are gonna
continue to be helping nevada come out
of
uh this pandemic in this economic
downturn so that means
making sure that folks have uh access to
to health care uh if if you know our
folks are sick
then you know that's not gonna help our
economy turn around and
then we're gonna have to look at trying
to um protect jobs
um hopefully replace many of the jobs
that have been lost um
and make sure that we have an
environment where uh as the economy
turns around
um you know i think our economy can can
grow with it
um we're still going to be looking at
diversifying our economy we are seeing
right now
that an economy for a state that lives
primarily on a couple of different
industries is not the way to
to responsibly budget moving forward so
i think we're going to have to look at
diversifying our economy
broadening uh the sources that we rely
on to provide our communities basic
needs
that includes uh dealing with education
we
we worked really really hard to increase
per pupil spending only to
to get sued and have uh that in jeopardy
um and then we also are having our
families and children struggling with
distance learning
so we got to get them back in the
classroom we got to do it safely so
uh you know i think at the forefront
those are the things that we're going to
be looking at
um in you know in the immediate future
we obviously have redistricting to do
um we're not going to have numbers it
doesn't appear in time to complete that
process during session
but we will certainly start that process
and be ready if uh if we have to carry
it over beyond regular session
to do the job that that i think the
constitution mandates that we do
um just getting back quickly to the
funding obviously
we know why the funding deficit exists i
feel like every legislative session it's
always
there's never enough money to go around
what are you gonna do that's sort of
standard practice obviously these are
unusual circumstances
but the money that's come from the
federal government
how much of it has been used what hasn't
been used
and where is it going well you know
the the way that we got the federal
dollars that we we did receive
um um through uh the cares act
has been at the discretion of the
executive branch and how they spend it
so
uh we did form a subcommittee so that we
could ask questions ask those very uh
questions about use um uh at the last
meeting of the subcommittee
it was made clear that the money was
either already used or
had been uh you know slotted to be used
for said purposes by the end of the year
only to find out
by the end of the year that there were
extensions being granted
but you know for most states it was too
late for that because they had already
made it clear
that those dollars had to be expended by
the end of the year
so i believe all of those have been
expended or
are already slotted uh primarily to deal
with
uh the distribution of vaccines uh and
you know we are still hopeful that there
will be additional federal aid coming
um obviously that has not happened thus
far uh and it's been a disappointing
process
uh but you know uh we as nevada get less
of a return on our investment in federal
government than most states
and so um especially because we have
been
so uh so much worse uh hurt by the
pandemic as a state
uh we certainly are still hopeful that
um through leadership of uh senator
catherine cortez master who's been a
fearless fighter for us
um uh and our other uh you know uh
members of our
nevada delegation will continue to fight
for some support from federal government
uh to get additional support but you
know we are not returning
any of that money back to the federal
government uh we have needs still
uh to me to meet for our state are you
satisfied with the explanations from the
executive branch of
how the money has been spent yo well
look
we would you know i don't envy the
governor the governor has worked very
hard to try to listen to experts
uh both in the state and and nationally
um i'm not privy to the information that
that he and his team are so i'm not
going to second guess them in in the
decisions that he's had to make
um it's it's my job to continue to try
to help my constituents get the services
they need
uh and i don't envy anybody in a
position of having to make
the decisions that the governor's had to
make uh i don't think it's fair to
second guess it uh
but uh i'm not privy to the information
that he is
that that has guided the decisions that
he's making we just got to continue to
communicate
with the public about what's going on so
that they have confidence that
we are continuing to put their needs
first just to backtrack
isn't one of the lawmakers jobs to
second guess what
happens anywhere is that kind of the job
not to not to be overly critical but i
mean
second guessing is kind of part of the
job sometimes well
you know i think second guessing uh is
not i don't think that that's what we do
i mean i think that's maybe a cynical uh
view of what the legislative process is
uh we do look at the previous biennium
and make policy decisions moving forward
um and we made a policy decision to
allow the governor to
to distribute this money based on the
fact that he
was privy to information that that you
know very few are
about what was what was going on in the
country and in our state
so at moving forward these are federal
dollars these were not state dollars
um and they these were not dollars for
the most part other than work programs
um that were given to the legislature to
distribute so
um we we don't have authority um over
that pop of money and we're gonna work
with the the things that we do have
authority over
uh to shape our policies moving forward
and to the extent of that involves
uh reviewing what has been left on the
table what hasn't been addressed
um either because the cares dollars were
limited
in in in how they were doled out or
because we just have remaining needs
that need to be met we will continue to
look at those
i remember over the summer you and and
attorney general ford and others were
over at the grant sawyer building
discussing uh racial injustice uh police
reform during the black lives matter
protests
how much of that discussion will stretch
into the
legislative session i know it was
discussed at the special session to some
extent but
what do you want to see discussed when
all the lawmakers
are back up in carson city well i still
think that we're going to have
some discussions about social justice
and about community policing
and just ideas on how to best
uh you know protect the public i am
committed to making sure that
all of our stakeholders at the table
including the law enforcement community
i think that we avoid unintended
consequences when we have everybody at
the table
but i do think that there are you know
are
still ways that we can better police our
community
better provide criminal justice uh more
efficiently
and i think you know there are some ways
that we we use money that might not be
the most efficient
or the wisest way to use money whether
it's how we treat traffic tickets
um how we look at the the cash bail
system
uh i i think you know continuing to look
at
crime and punishment and whether or not
we are being smart with our our
resources
and uh incarcerating the most dangerous
individuals
but not wasting taxpayer dollars um
housing people that don't pose
uh a heart a risk of harm to the
community so those are
conversations we'll continue to have but
we'll certainly have them with
uh law enforcement at the table or or
people who have been paroled and still
have not gotten out
of the state prison system for right
one reason or another right what
conversations or
have you had any conversations uh
leading up to this session with
uh sheriff lombardo for example uh other
law enforcement leaders across the state
about
you know union members about trying to
make put this
into action uh i have absolutely had
conversations i was just on the phone
with the sheriff a couple of days ago
um uh and um
one one of his members of his
administration and i
have a a working relationship and are
committed to reconnecting uh next week
to just talk about where we are and
where we can find common ground
uh i have asked them tell me you know
what is it that would help you better
um meet the community's needs meet your
agency's needs
um and let's see if we can find a way to
help you do that so for example if we're
going to make any
criminal justice adjustments to save
money um i
have no problem with earmarking some of
that savings so that
law enforcement is better able to to
police the community
so those are conversations that we've
had we'll continue to have um
i think that the conversation with uh
the police union has unfortunately
become far more political and partisan
than i think it warrants and so we're
going to work on that uh i've committed
with them
uh to meeting with them weekly during
session and i'll follow through on that
to hear them out and and make sure that
those perspectives are reflected in the
policy discussions
just to quickly wrap up here and i me
you and i but you discussed this at the
beginning
um this is going to be a difficult
legislative session
in in your experience in in public
service
just how challenging is the task for
you and all lawmakers to
to get the business done given the
limited resources
uh and also just given the circumstances
of the pandemic
it's going to be incredibly difficult i
don't know that i i am aware of any
session
that uh has presented the kind of
challenges that we're facing right now
we're facing challenges with respect to
the the tough budget decisions that
we're going to have to make um but we're
also
facing i think political challenges
about rhetoric and
about how we're going to govern um and
how we're going to lead
i have always said that i believe
there's power both in the majority and
in the minority and [ __ ]
and you know crafting policy and i think
that we all are going to have to
uh put partisanship aside at times and
either advance policies that we think
are good for the state or mitigate
policies that we think
maybe aren't so good for the state and
if any um
part of the machine walks away and
doesn't participate in that i think
we're doing a disservice
to to to nevada so i am hopeful that uh
the four leaders of our four caucuses
can continue
to talk um i do have good working
relationships with
both uh minority robin titus as well as
uh james settlement over in the senate
and we'll continue to
extend an olive grant to have those
conversations i suspect they're going to
be
fewer bills overall because of some of
the structural limitations that we may
experience
um based on kovit and so we're going to
really have to focus
on the nuts and bolts of state
functioning
and meeting our state's basic needs and
they're going to be some issues that are
going to have to wait uh for a
subsequent session to
be dealt with a lot of questions
all right uh sir i appreciate the time
and uh
good luck up in carson city we'll be in
touch thank you so much john take care
be safe have a good day